wow that is beautiful it's going to be a
beautiful
[Music]
day put in your
hat Jo these guys are are beating us I
didn't think they would this not
[Music]
actually s close blood sces yeah look at
that look at that here we
go
wow that is beautiful it's going to be a
beautiful day Daniel here with DM men's
lifestyle and today we're going hunting
in South Africa I'm not going to do it
alone I'm going to do it with Don and
jock who are also part of the DM team so
the idea is to get them at the lodge oh
here Donnie is already good morning good
morning this place is called Tom andom
and so we're going to do this hunting
trip with a guide as well and we're all
going to meet up at uh the lodge for
some breakfast it's a little bit chilly
this morning huh yeah but it's ni to be
out of nature it's not not a lot of
people that's sleeping over here which
is nice usually it's extremely busy
because this place is so popular right
next to the
Riv oh there he is Jo good morning good
morning it's go are you ready for this
day I'm ready ready to have some
breakfast yep let's get to it wow
beautiful good morning good morning how
are you guys good and you good good good
good good oh there's a nice fire already
oh that's the breakfast area
good oh it is cold this morning
Chuck M I like those socks it looks
familiar let me let me do a closeup here
it's O I think it's the same as mine
check it out check it
out and what do you
know Don you got the same what of looks
like we're a
team ooh I'm going to start with the
coffee and I BR my flask for the day as
well ooh these bread are awesome I think
it's a belon
bread all
right I'm having a big breakfast today
because we going to walk far and this is
not the only thing I'm going to have
we're also going to have some
omelets can I pray for
us thank you Father for this beautiful
day please bless us today with the deer
we need and thank you for the food in
Jesus name amen
[Music]
amen
ooh here we go that's The Omelette
donkey
donkey this is going to keep us full
huh the whole
day we're going to walk over those deer
and find them this will give us the
energy we need hey Peter hello hello
Hello nice to meet you nice to meet you
too so Peter he's going to be our gu and
he's going to take us into the field
it's pleasure to meet you and it will be
great to take you out all right right
thank you let's do
it so we stopped quickly because we're
going to shoot with a d and after this
we're going to go hunting but it's the
first time that Donnie and jock is going
to shoot an Impala so we just got to
make sure we know what we're
doing how did that feel
[Laughter]
that
was oh you did it was too
close we get off
yeah sure that's a
gun yeah oh nice shot a my Square yeah
if if that was a buck it'll be down on
yeah yeah so Jo you
next anym WoW Jo
that's my goodness huh
jeez I don't think I'm impressed with
myself why why do I always have to go
after the the best guy you know I
mean
woo how was that Daniel man it's good
but I can't hear
anything Donnie jock me it's like the
Three
Musketeers I think we're ready to go
hunting yeah let's
go
wow my goodness yeah this is a beautiful
spot
M that's what we caught those basss the
other
day but uh Peter how's this going to
work stalk first and then hunt and then
and try to get them we're going to um
watch over the fields now and check
where all they grazing and then we're
going to move in where they are and look
which Ram you can take out okay yeah all
right and um what deer do you have here
on the farm we've got a few species um
from small it's um steambach Dyer um
springb um Impalas Nala Sables golden
wild the Beast um Kus elen games Bo um
leway um water B so um gir giraffes Bas
sure that's not the normal zebra yeah so
we have quite a lot of species here and
I I saw you got beautiful on so it's not
just the spring Bo but you have a white
spring Bo and black one basically the
grand slam right Grand Slam yeah and the
Impalas also we have the black Impalas
okay yeah so all right yeah we have big
Varity yeah but we're not going to go
for those today because we don't have
that much money we'll go for the normal
Impalas today so let's go and andstock
them and maybe maybe uh Donnie first
what do you say yeah know let's do
it we saw some of them down there in
those trees now I just need to get down
there so we see them right there in
those trees we're going to go around and
get them
so Donnie is walking closer to the guide
because he's got to shoot first and
we're going to stay a little bit behind
but follow them the wind is not good at
the moment because I can feel it's
pushing this way and they are right
there so if it just turns a little bit
they will smell
us but you can see he's been walking
here they're right behind those
trees right
here
it's a little bit difficult with
this thick bush here so we're going to
try to go
around
excited
right we're gaining ground but they're
right over
there
did you get it don't think so and
they're running past a
now so that was the first
shot this bigy spooky no they are a bit
spooky it was not an easy shot so don is
not sure that he got it so we're just
going to go to make sure I haven't seen
one that that fell that fell then got
shot all right so there's not one that
fell maybe if one is hit we call it qu
and Arcons then uh we got to Trail
it oh
look porcupine Jo Co you want it put it
in your
hat
now we just need to see if we can see
any
blood so no blood found so Peter what
are we going to do we're going to move
around here check um check if they give
us another chance mhm and then we go
move um back to the vehicle and maybe
move to other spot if they're not going
to give us um another another chance
because they spook quite spooked now
yeah okay they were spooked before we
shot right so we'll see so it's going to
be a challenge yeah but we like
challenges all right so we're just on
the trail now and you can see where they
went that's a nice
one
something killed this poor
guy I think we lost them yeah but I
think we can CL a GE near the bird hide
okay maybe they went that side all right
and then otherwise we come back just go
to the vehicle okay sounds good
yeah we're not exactly sure where they
are but we'll find
[Music]
them
man those
birds when they make noise like that it
feels like they're telling the deer
watch out watch
out all right guys we changed the
location and we spotted them so they are
across this little Hill
here it's so warm we took our jackets
off
Don and then they're moving over
there the palas we saw them running just
behind these trees
[Applause]
here
we're in the bush and every guy's got to
do his
thing toilet number one toilet number
two just listen to that
quiet look at this big
grasshopper where is it
now saw a minute ago there he is look at
that
guy
so there are a lot of different pigs but
this is a Art Park hole so you can see
it here there are many of them here on
the farm and there's also flak Fara
water Hogs so if we see
one I really want to shoot one going to
make some nice uh cheese sausage oh
there's another one oh
h
there are
many there are many snakes here as well
so always got to be
careful where we put our
feet I've been looking for snakes the
whole
time theala spotted us so they just ran
and now we got to find some
again
there there some Bock running they too
far
away I should have put my other camera
because the quality of the GoPro is not
that
good I don't see anything anything
nothing but I think they're behind this
hill
here they
are he going to shoot the one on the
left there's a ram there we're just
waiting for the right
time yeah now as in with the mix they if
they're that far away uh it gets a
little bit difficult and also the ram is
now in the middle of all the others so
you can easily just um accidentally
shoot some of the others so it's not
what you want to do so we'll have to get
closer
again oh that was close Don yeah let's
go get
him so what we're going to do now is
we're going to try to flank
them can see them
there so we need to go
around just a little bit to the left
there's a kudu there as
well but that's not our Target
today I think they they spotted us so
they they're running and checking us
out you can see them
there they are clever and they're a bit
wild Jo these guys are are beating us
man yep I didn't think they were this
smart
actually we saw some of them here in the
bushes
we're going after
[Applause]
them they
here do this is
fresh you can you can smell
it
did you guys see it
right right
there
I think he got him here now we just need
to see where they're
going yeah that one's not feeling too
good you can see him they that one he's
going to fall
soon all right I think we got to go and
Trail him
yeah finally we got one huh after all
this time I think we've been tracking
these guys for the whole morning the
whole
morning
the
nice
H done when you do something like this
you you appreciate animals a lot more
yeah definitely compared to just buying
it from the store Don mhm yeah more
personal
yeah hold on Donnie your first one
thanks hold
on you see the thing is a lot of people
complain when they hear about people
going hunting but then those same people
go to the store and just buy their meat
so they just eat it but it's it's worse
you know because they pump Those Animals
full of so much unhealthy stuff just to
get bigger and grow and
then this is this is better you kill it
yourself you know exactly where the meat
comes from and then you appreciate so
much more so it is is actually a bit
emotional but the problem is in this
area if there are too many of them then
there's not enough food for all of them
as well sicknesses can break out a lot
of things but the first one is down we
got two more to
go blood scores yeah has to be
done right yeah
so the easy part is hunting it but then
uh when that's done you got to carry it
so we're going to carry it all the way
to the
truck it's just around the corner there
it is
finally you
[Laughter]
ready po
sorry see you guys the for the smaller
ones we should go for the smaller
ones I think we just load it like this
all right we're going to quickly take
this back just do the necessary Cuts
take out the stomach all those kind of
stuff and then uh we have two more for
me and for jock Donnie now your family
has meat for a few months
yeah all right let's
go guys now the thing is when you're out
of here in the middle of Africa I mean
you get thirsty and so this is the best
thing that you can get the water stays
cold for long I have to agree I have to
agree this is awesome cman BS great to
keep things cool
yeah so you see there in the
distance is a
Bara yeah is not a zebra Bara and then
on to the right you can see the B Beast
as well under the
trees it's Jo
turn they're
running we want a ram but uh there's not
a
ram so we need to look for
others
they're right in there but uh they know
we are here so we're actually just
waiting until they move out a little
bit
man they spotted us so they made a run
for it okay I just realized when my
alarm went off the
Impala went to fetch my daughter from
school it was the
reminder I'm I'm sorry
j
so
close was so close I just want to show
you there's another one of these big
ones look at
that there's a beautiful one here a
beautiful impola Ram we saw and J might
be able to shoot
it it's right over
there the furthest
end
so we
are just moving closer towards
it from
ni I think you got it but it's I
definitely H it but I don't know where I
hit it so Jo got it but he wounded it
and so we need to go after
it so Jo definitely got it but uh it's
here in the
side so we got to shoot it again can see
us over
there
just to the left of the
orex stady on that shot so might have
been in the rip
somewhere let's good
see all right Jo got his uh
Impala how do you feel jock it feels
good I I wish I just shot it with one
shot but uh still the job is done right
yeah
congratulations
monkey first one your first one yeah
thank you for your life yeah we hunting
with your first kill this is a must need
some blood on your face to
appreciate the
animal
there you go first
one there we go Jo finally got his now
we're going to go back we're going to
have some lunch and then um I got to I
got to do mine I feel a little bit
emotional about it because it's not easy
to see this right but I don't want to
support really
anymore companies who just make animals
fat pump them full of
hormones and uh then you have to eat it
and
um this is a lot better it's just it's
just you get your hands there to
yourself instead of letting other people
do it for you and you appreciate it a
lot
more
this is a Bor to book this is what we
call
them those lines are so
defined H
beautiful but he's not our Target today
so we can't shoot
them now the idea is to work the meat as
soon as possible before it goes bad
and you guys do you speak English or
only Africans n Africans okay okay so
just to explain this is Nik he's the
expert he's helping us because we don't
have a lot of time I also need to go
shoot mine but he's the expert so he's
just busy here butchering and uh yeah
he's speaking Africans that's our first
language because it's their first deer
right they need to eat either the balls
because it's a Ram or they can choose
the lever so J what do you choose Li Li
and uh it needs to be raw Donnie what do
you choose LI or I don't think I shoot I
didn't shoot this
[Laughter]
book you got to choose which one I know
give me give me a second to decide the
choice is difficult they they have to
decide and also you see the blood on on
Jo's face yep that's what needs to be H
happening and then there is a small
piece I must give you a bigger piece
okay okay the rule is you must chew it
mhm before you swallow okay so you can't
just swallow the whole thing okay you
must chew a little bit okay not in um
swallow you must chew it mhm and then
swallow oh that's disgusting
joke it's like
sushi she not
fish po sushi
[Laughter]
[Music]
well done well
done the next up is uh
Donnie's Impala there he goes so don you
know what this
means I forgot something in the car it
means we were we were busy with your
buck so you're got to eat deliver
now just think it's
shshi little bit fish
isim
yeah yeah bush bush
fishes you only have to do it once Don
the the second time you you should you
don't have to do it again it's the first
one that's why you have to do
[Laughter]
it you swallow the whole thing you
didn't even chew I did I chew I chew two
two times twice I'm
gone all right guys um NCO is going to
finish up for us here um the sun is
almost setting so we need to go just to
have enough time so that I can shoot
mine as well let's go for the
Beast there they
go you can see the a little bit
different from the normal VAB Beast
because they have this golden color
beautiful all right so we're back in the
field and uh I'm thinking about shooting
a spring so we can show you guys what
our um National deer looks
like
we're using this little Bush here as
cover behind it but they're really far
we might take the
chance
oh tried to stalk them but uh man
they're too
smart they're gone so i' got to try to
find some other
[Music]
ones there is a l
b and the is call
row
that's exactly what we need the spring
box there's one ram standing there
but we're not allowed to shoot from the
car because um they do some wild rides
here Safari drives every now and then
and uh they need them to be okay with
people in the car so but they're not
afraid but the moment we're going to get
out he's going to run there is already
[Music]
moving
there are a few spring BS here but we
can't shoot them because they the the
white ones they're more
special so we're going to try to find a
a nice
one but not
these so we couldn't get the spring box
they're too wild but we seeing something
us right over there and they they've
already seen us so we're going to try to
go around
we're going to get closer they're far
away
they
so we're chasing these
Impalas but every time where we just
want to shoot them they see us and they
move and you can't shoot them like that
so now again they saw us and they went
over the hill so we're
chasing better he'll
be
this
all right so it was a very very far shot
but I got him but I think
his his leg got the worst of it it's not
what we want so we need to go and uh try
to kill him as soon as we
can
I think uh I think we got him
now all right guys we know now for sure
he's done it's over
there oh
oh my first Impala there he is it feels
it feels sad you
know there we
go thank you for your
life it's not easy taking your life
but um yeah it's going to feed us for a
month or so so let's get him
[Music]
home thank you B pleasure I hope you
enjoyed your all three of you yeah good
not see forward to happy year again we
will come again definitely Pizza you
made it special made it amazing I say it
in English Pizza but it's Peter that's
how you said it correctly thank you so
much
oh let's
go guys so we walked really far for this
guy we're carrying him now Donnie and Jo
they're helping me there we
go that's the one thing and we got to
probably carry this how many meters do
you think he said uh two two
kilm let's do
it yeah this one was was quite far this
is this is look guys so
look it's because of him that that we
could have gone out and shoot these
amazing things and then also Peter thank
you guys so much and then uh man it go
so fast these two are already done yeah
quick it's the professional hands
of but L um they haven't eat Li yet
because can did not no he
hasn't
sh before H are you sure we're not we
we're we're not too sure Luke yeah let
let's watch because we have proof of
these two yeah so so next time and next
time so we got some group pressure here
so what you do a group pressure you say
no but in this case because they're my
friends I will say yes a small piece the
rules are if it's if it's if you've
never hunted before if you shoot your
buck you need to eat that liver doesn't
sound that good now but I'll I'll eat a
small small piece guys yeah all right so
now next time when we ask you if you've
done it then you've got video
proof you can trust my word I'm a
Christian I'm a rebor Believer my word
is my
bie so I'm asking niku here if he wants
to eat a little piece with me and also
the kids over
[Music]
there they will look look yeah we'll do
it
together sound yeah
[Music]
and we're going to do it look look
one I
win it's not good
yes now we believe you now we need
coffee or something watch
[Laughter]
this you that was Terri
guys it's getting late here so what we
going to do is we're going to prepare
the meat and then
um oh man I still have
this I don't want to speak because I
want to throw up why you
laughing so we're going to finish up
here with the meat and uh I'll show in
another day what it looks like when we
sit down and have some dinner maybe with
Nikita hey guys we're back home
this is all the meat we have enough here
for the next few
months this is almost halfway full we're
going to take some of them we're going
to work them we're going to make some
belong which we here in South Africa
call beef jerky buong but it's just a
lot better and nicer and uh right now
we're going to have a barbecue just to
taste
it the fire is going and while that's
going we're going to prepare the
[Music]
food all right guys check this out so
this
is the Impala meat we call it a ROK here
in South Africa but this is the guy
we're going to use to make some steak
for me for Jo for Nikita as well and
then we have some leftovers because jock
and I we're hitting the gym and so this
is really good protein but um I'm going
to make a nice sauce here here for it
first of all some olive
oil so this is the the sauce that I'm
going to make and we're going to put it
on the beef and we're going to put it on
with this guy next up we got some time I
like to get the natural one because it's
just so much
better next up we have some garlic ooh
you cannot do without without any
garlic oh we going to put a lot a little
bit
more
woo nice and then I'm just going to add
some salt oh I'm ready for this guy bad
breath combo yeah
exactly look at that you can get that's
lean not a lot of fat and very important
no hormones so
good cool they are ready here we go so
this is the traditional fry broi so what
we do we just use uh for now whole wheat
you can use any bread but we're going to
add some butter
there not too much we're going to try to
keep it healthy but a loves her
butter so we can to add it there and
then these are the ingredients so first
up tomatoes that goes on some onions now
Jo of course he cut everything into
pieces uh for me the traditional way is
it's got to be round but um Jo why did
you cut this in pieces So Daniel wanted
thin slices um because he's a py eater
so I I figured I might as well just chop
it up so um then he can't complain about
it being well not
thin okay it's all good so then we add
the onions there we go and
then cheese now the thing is when I grew
up we were five kids right so my mom
would add cheese just like that just a
little bit you know to save money um but
since this has been a special trip and
says it is a very special time because
we went we stalked we hunted our first
Impalas we're going to make this for Nik
we're going to make it special
so this is how much cheese I'm going to
add more cheese a
more
and
more that is the traditional Bri brei
but what I'm going to do because I know
Jo Jo you love this as well chili ch
there we go we're going to add some
jellop penos now all we do we put this
on like that and then that's going to go
on the
barbecue always use the onion just to
kill the germs and make it
clean Jo be getting closer we almost
ready
[Music]
yeah okay guys we're going to put it on
and then when we turn it
around we're going to start putting on
our special
sauce that is
done ah it's
hot look at all that
garlic
[Laughter]
you oh it's going to be good check this
out
out look at that look at
that yeah hey I'm something delicious
yeah here you are finally my
queen are you hungry oh man I've been
hungry for the last hour cuz I've been
smelling these like the good food so
Nikita is very specific she likes her
meat medium rare
yes please not graia it's almost ready
you can sit
medium rare with a bit of love okay
sounds
good here we go here we go this is the
moment it's the Moment of Truth medium
rare let me check let me
check is it medium
rare medium bit more
medium wait look give the P back wait
wait wait bit more medium stop the
recording but I think it's still going
to be
good we want food we want thank you give
it a sh okay let's check this
one sorry I'm in your face but um
yeah should shouldn't be a bit more
medium rare n yeah next time next time
give it a tast I think it's still going
to be good I think it's still going to
be good yeah is it enough
salted is enough
salt just it definitely enough
Sal good guys do you mind if we just
quickly pray yeah yeah sure let's do it
job would you would you pray for I'll
pray for us right Lord I want to thank
you for this amazing opportunity to be
able to to get this this good me meat
this lean meat Lord on in the right way
as well but I want to thank you that we
can share this
moment and um just enjoy this wonderful
food Lord want to pray in your name amen
amen let's
eat here we
go what does Impala taste
like M good yeah I want more nice
all right there we go there we go this
is what we call Fry
Brees all right nice o I'm going to at
the cheese I do want the all one which
one do you want one with the most cheese
can I take it with my hand you can how
was the hunting very
good guys it's been an amazing time so
far now we are plucking the fruits of
our labor and um looks like Nikita is
enjoying it
it and Jo is enjoying it as well Jo good
yeah so guys this is the end of the
video please subscribe if you haven't
done so already we bring out videos
every Friday everything has got to do
with men so we'll see you in the next
video bye bye